and they have weird things like oh i can
speak my reality into existence and then
i can work to
achieve whatever my so all of these
things are very shitty it's basically
putting the human being
in the place of god or saying that oh
these are certain laws that if you do
them
you're bound to have uh success and the
reason it
ropes people in is because they take
certain elements of religion
so that it can be palatable to those who
believe in religion
i say oh yeah my religion teaches
something like this but when you dig
deeper into it
it says very specific unique way of
thinking of
that goes outside of what the dean tells
you to do
[Music]
and i'll say this most women who say
they're against pelogeny would still
might marry the prophet
as a
why high value men high value men
melt away the resistance of women
[Music]
assalamu and sisters welcome back to
another podcast of the ttm the three
muslims of realist podcast
in the dunya we are back again
with the two brothers brother khalil and
brother
this is part three of the gen series
what we talking about today
we are talking about genies
but specifically psychedelics
yes the psychological there we go
all right bismillah brother what are
psychedelics for people that don't even
know what the term means
it's a good question um and i think to
clarify
they're a type of drug also known as
hallucinogens so
when we look at them or drugs generally
speaking
they're different classes so there are
some stimulants there's some
sedatives there are some that are more
dangerous than others
there are some that affect you mentally
psychologically physically
all three uh hallucinogens or
psychedelics are things that
it's kind of in the name they make you
see things hear things and they change
your state of consciousness
and that's the thing that people in
today's day and age are really trying to
hone in on
so people will speak about all the
states of consciousness or psychedelics
of
almost the most altered states of
consciousness you could probably get
in in waking life right so
they and you would have definitely heard
some of these so lsd
shrooms dmt which is probably going to
be the main focus of
today's episode there's also masculine
which comes from
cactus there's other ones that i made in
labs like 2cb
etc so there's a whole range there there
are a whole range of different drugs
um but yeah i'll i'll maybe ask angel
if you want to elaborate and i probably
missed a few things and
probably me know a bit more about this
than me
i mean after all on hell is the king of
psychedelics
so we got romney as the king of intimacy
we got me as the the king of
psychedelics now
you already know bro what are you what
are you the king of
i'm the king of podcasts bro
i wanted to add something real quick bro
when you
you mentioned that people are taking
this today at uh
at a number astronomically higher than
you know ever before
why would someone in their right mind
today want to take anything like this
you went in a little bit on
they want to experience a higher level
of consciousness but
what are they trying to do
to be honest with you i think we have to
look a bit
more history and how it's evolved so
many of these drugs have only been found
fairly recently i think dmt is a case
study
in terms of when it was discovered in
the western world and was speaking
specifically
about the western world there's a
chemical it was first synthesized in
1920s
it wasn't even known to be a hedo
synergen or psychedelic so to speak
until the 1950s i believe 1956 and then
there was the 1960s which was
when psychedelics started popping right
and that's when everyone was starting to
take it and everyone's taking lsd and
wearing those
uh tie-dye clothes and everyone was
being called hippies etc and then the
war on drugs happen
so really there's one not been that much
research on these strokes so when people
say they're completely safe okay
well for as far as we know they're
completely safe to get back to your
question now
we're living more and more in a godless
world so atheism is starting to creep up
but what we've seen as well one thing is
atheism isn't sustainable so when people
start living in a world without law
without
god this creates a void
in the soul and so we now see very
prominent atheists like sam harris for
example where there's a meditation act
and there are many atheists who say they
are spiritual and that many people want
to explore this
psychedelics are seen as the almost
pinnacle
spiritual states whether they are or not
isn't what we're
discussing at this specific moment but
people who take them to think
i'll be able to explore and because i
don't have any laws
to govern me so in christianity it could
be seen as farm kika or
a form of witchcraft by taking these
drugs and other religions may say you
know don't take them like islam for
example
but other people who aren't religious
well they're agnostic or atheist
they see this as i can do have my own
experiences and come up with my own
conclusions for myself so there's that
feeling of control now there's that
feeling of
adventure exploration and they take it
seriously as well most people don't take
psychedelics consistently
unless they're serious about it because
it's not for fun it's not like
a joint for example someone who smokes a
joint immediately
socially same thing with alcohol tobacco
etc so it's very different and people
have to realize
it's not the same as for example meth or
cocaine or
heroin and it's not the same as alcohol
or weed
though weed is similar to it in some
ways and
they each have similarities to each
other
it's it's a very unique class of drugs
and that's why it has
its own niche but this niche isn't small
like you said it's been
growing and it's now reached a point
where it's almost unprecedented
and you have many states legalizing
these things or actually looking into it
so
just down the road from me not down the
road literally but down the road is
imperial college london they've opened
the psychedelic research center i
remember a couple years back
literally two years ago from you know
around this time
last year around this time two years ago
i remember being at school and some
someone was sending me this link and he
was like hey look at this king's college
a very famous university
is running cyber trials and we were too
young to even like
think about applying not that we wanted
to but it was 18 or something
and you have to have like mild
depression and you were laughing and
saying hey look
you can now trip for free in in the uk
in london and we were laughing but
it's crazy when you think about it
because not that long ago these things
were
heavily criminalized so we're seeing a
transformation
now more than ever before
i have um and before i even speak how's
my voice from here
sounds fun fun yeah yeah so i have this
uh bottle of soap
it's a casto or castor soap
it's all very clean only has like a few
ingredients all natural
um i think it's called uh the company's
dr bronner's
or something like that
huh castillo soap yeah yeah that's
that's it exactly
it's legit it's legit right you don't
even have to use that much because it's
so
strong it's so important you just have
to dilute it so then bro
on the bottle it literally speaks about
like a psychedelic treatment to
be able to heal people who are you know
going through these mental issues and
it's like
guys like if you break it down
it's very simple all right
people take psychedelics for what reason
experience more exactly everyone wants
to experience more so you're taking a
psychedelic so that you experience more
well isn't that what religion is isn't
that what god is you're experiencing
more
you know yeah yeah go ahead
why why didn't they put that on the
soapbox i don't understand
the program i don't know man i don't
know if you actually look into it
it's um the guy he's uh
i think he's dead now so you know may
may allah accept him if it's in his
cards but
um i think he was christian and he was
real into like
helping people out healing the planning
and like his message and
his mission was nice but i think it's
the people after
him now that are trying to like add
these little things on to it where
um the other psychedelic treatment i
don't know bro if
actually give me one second i'm gonna
bring this bottle in here
bro listen before you go all right this
man already took off
guys for anyone listening i have a
bottle of dr broner's too which i use
it's very good
but he's not christian guys he's jewish
and
every single bottle i got there was some
to a greater or lesser degree of
religious propaganda
i don't know why that is jewish
propaganda or new age propaganda
jewish new age it started with jewish
and it was closer to when he was alive
it was more like jewish it was more like
uh religious and moral values of him i'm
sure angel can agree
that was superimposed in all of these
packaging today it's a little more
new age but so bro look at this
first off you're looking at this
packaging and it's all
it's already overloaded there's like too
much here all right and it's like all
over just all this writing everywhere
and um right here i can actually get
that in there
it starts saying the psychedelics
and i'll read it off because y'all y'all
not gonna be able to see it but it says
uh psychedelic assisted therapy
was recently granted breakthrough
designation
by the fda for use in treating ptsd and
major
depressive disorder epidemics for which
pharmaceutical drugs have fallen short
and then it just goes on to kind of like
hype it up for like a better words
i'm not surprised you see that you see
that over there taking a shower bro
before you know it you want to trip on
some shrooms
you don't have to die so i mean exactly
no i'm seeing like the average person
bro like yeah yeah yeah
it's subtle bro it works in very subtle
ways
yeah this is a really interesting point
because
when people speak about these these
things these
so-called tools or plant medicines they
actually get really obsessed with it
and many people try and defend dmt who
are muslims and say well it's not a bad
thing but is it a bad
thing if you actually look at people who
don't even do ayahuasca just do dmt
they actually res the things that they
do resemble
acts of worship in a sense because one
they'll
start researching it and then they'll
build up this library of knowledge and
they'll try and
set a good intention before the trip and
say this is my intention i want to do
this and i want to have this and i want
to gain this out of the experience
and i want to get closer and become more
spiritual etc they'll say a lot of
things
after the experience they'll feel so
grateful for what they had so they'll
have this sugar and they'll have this
gratefulness
they'll start praising the experience
and
having this gratitude that no human
being or object or
world they think should have they'll
start praising the entities and
feel connected to it they'll start
actually encouraging other people to do
it
and some of them even actually make
hezero they'll make a literal migration
to the amazon to south america so if you
look at
even if they say oh no it's not it's not
worship
okay fine you may think that all the
acts you've been doing
resemble they mirror a type of worship
and
then people who go into ayahuasca that
that's a whole
ritual in and of itself and that it has
thousands of years proving that
uh yeah it's mad and so they'll do
things like this so they'll start a
brand
they'll make herbal teas they'll do
something and they'll place their
messaging in there and then
they'll immortalize their experience and
pass on this message
as if it's some prophetic message yeah
that's how it works and
uh when i've taken shrooms like if you
take enough shrooms like listen you are
submitting to the shrooms
there's no if ands or buts like i
remember
doing uh over an eighth and
guys that's that's a lot i'll just say
right here that's a lot
and i remember taking this stuff and um
[Music]
anytime that i would start to think
about something
and i was uh i guess you could say
coming out of the present like not being
fully present
the shrooms would basically make me want
to throw up
and it was almost like slapping me like
trying to pull me back into like
only this specific mode of experience
only experiencing the present yeah i get
it you know the presence is nice
but like we also have intellect for a
reason
we have a logic for reasons so it's like
this one thing
this uh plant this fungus i should say
this fungus is over here only trying to
make me experience
uh the reality in this this way
but not in the other ways um so in in
essence
it is forcing me to submit it'll force
anyone else to submit just a little
throwaway yeah that's every single one
of these has that same characteristic
whether it be dmt or
subscribing though they'll make you
submit and you have to submit and if you
go in thinking it's
going to be a fun ride you're going to
see clowns you're going to have a
terrible time because
that's the nature of it so you have to
submit which it's never submission this
is also submission but
what are you submitting to and some say
i don't know i'm trying to figure it all
out
well i don't know i mean if you really
knew what you were submitting to i don't
know i don't think you take those steps
and i want to introduce a character here
now because i think is relevant to what
he was saying
there's a guy called terence mckenna and
i've read a lot of his works and i've
listened to
i don't know how many hours of his
lectures you've probably heard of him
another guy also really big in this
field is
anna watts both of these guys are dead
by the way but they get millions and
millions and millions of views
on youtube every single day and there's
a reason why because
let's take terence mckenna for example
he in the 60s and onwards up until he
died in the 90s
was a huge proponent of psychedelics he
went to he was one of the first people
to go to the amazon rainforest and try
ayahuasca with his brother dennis who's
still alive
and with some of his friends they were
already big on shrooms they
were very studied as well well studied
well educated
very fluent they had a unique way of
speaking terence was very
vivid with his language he used to
describe the dmt experiences the
entities he saw
he would encourage people to do things
in a certain way to take three talks now
when people talk about dmt they'll speak
about three talks he coin
when people talk about heroic dose on
shrooms taking five grams
in silent darkness as well he would
highly encourage that that was him and
he said
when you take that much in those
settings then the
the shroom will speak to you you know
and when i first heard that that was
weird but
it kind of makes sense now because when
you take that much
you're forcing yourself into that
position in that environment
of course you're going to hear something
you're going to be in contact with
something and use the joke and say it's
the aliens
it kind of makes sense now so there are
these individuals
who spread the word of these things they
are like diaries they
they were respected as almost the same
way and all the other but i don't mean
in a bad way but the same way some
people respect scholars it was the same
thing
so that's the kind of world we live in
it's a religion in and of itself if you
think about it
i mean it's crazy too and and i got a
question and i want to ask ahmed here
because
uh i want to get into this but it's
crazy that you're saying this because
when someone takes psychedelics all it's
doing is allowing them to experience
more all right but they're experiencing
more
of something that is already there like
you know like i'm not saying that
they're gonna experience the creator
but the creator's already there i'm not
saying they're gonna experience gins but
the jinns are already there i'm not
saying they're gonna experience another
dimension
but the other dimension is already there
you feel me so i'm not claiming anything
here but what i am saying
is that when someone does take
psychedelics
they experience more and it's crazy to
think that
everyone has this and they this innate
thing where they want to experience more
they want to know the truth
everyone wants to know the creator they
want to know why they're here what's the
purpose here
and then they take these psychedelics
and then you have these people who are
so
closed off so dumb and and i say that i
say it like that i'm not saying it to
speak bad about them not saying it at
all like that
but in the quran it says like are are
the um
the believers the same as a disbeliever
like is someone who is deaf the same as
someone who is not deaf it's someone who
is dumb
the same as someone who is not dumb it's
someone who is blind the same as someone
who is not blind
so i'm only saying it like this where
it's like you have these people who
they finally see it they have the
experience
but they still close off they still
don't believe it at that point where
it's like ah okay yeah maybe there is
something else
they're like i know it was just a it was
a hallucination
it wasn't real you know what i mean so
it's crazy to think
that there are people that are so
atheist that even when they do something
to experience more they just write it
off as a simple hallucination
you know i got like evidence to suggest
oh no tobacco you know saying so there
was a study we spoke about
last time the john hopkins university
study at the time
so there's a percentage there was a
study done with 2
500 people so for people who aren't
following we were talking about a study
done
with 2500 people reviewing their dmt
experiences the most profound one one of
the questions was
the experience was more real than
everyday waking consciousness
and 81 percent said yes
at the time so during the experience 81
said it felt more real than real
after the experience only 65 said that
so people then like you say they they
have an experience and then they'll say
they'll go back they'll go back and say
no no i can't have been wrong so they'll
try and deny it not saying it's a good
thing
people are acknowledging it but it's a
reality as well so
in normal uh yeah basically
let me jump that kind of study follows
that yeah and add
that you have different psychologists so
you have
carl young who's very very well known
very famous
he even wrote letters to sigmund freud
and would say that you know in his
psycho in his
psychological works that if he
couldn't figure out a patient he'd drop
his astrological charts
right so he was very much into magic and
the way he talked about these entities
was oh
this is split off parts of your psych
here this is a psychological projection
or this is archetype so
it would be explained in a certain way
that someone that doesn't believe in
religion
could still make sense of these
experiences and continue on in this
in this dark path you also have someone
like joseph campbell
and joseph campbell wrote um i forget
the name of the book the many masks of
god or the many faces of god but
their idea people like carl young and
joseph campbell their idea of what god
is is that it's just a human collective
conscious projection
so we as human beings we have each of us
have an individual consciousness
they believe that all human beings
together had a collective
conscious like we all formed like one
great soul and everything in the world
had a soul everything
formed one gigantic soul and that that
was god and this philosophically was
called pantheism
pantheism is based on god is one and all
with everything
so that's how they explained it and
that's how they saw it and
oh heaven isn't really heaven it's just
you know getting to a higher level hell
is people that want to be away from this
type of consciousness and so forth so
they had their own explanations for it
such that they replaced god with
themselves
so someone who's atheist can still look
into the works of carl young
or um joseph campbell or these people
and still hold on to their atheist
belief but continue in this path and if
we look at it from
the point of view of the previous
episode was which and and the first
episode talked about messengers of
deception and aliens and so forth
to the shaytan it doesn't matter what
you do as long as you're not worshiping
allah so if they can get
the christian to come believe by saying
that oh this is christian
type stuff this is actually the holy
spirit basically they can get the
atheists in by saying oh this is the
collective unconscious
they can get muslims in by saying oh no
this is i'll get into the muslim stuff
later but
you know so from from shaitaan's goal
isn't necessarily that you worship
shaytaan although people do that
shaytan's goal is that you don't worship
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and to
misguide as many people as possible
by any means necessary so this is how
the atheist people
tend to interpret their experience and
they have their own
that back up that have an alternative
narrative for all of these things
i wanna just sounds like the new age
stuff very much so
very much so they look they they worship
they worship carl young
like they really look after him he's
he's like seen as an island but yeah
anyway just to quickly like jump on that
like there was this one part of a study
where it says 28
before the experience before the
encounter with these entities said that
they identify as atheists
after only ten percent so that's almost
the third uh yeah that's almost
two-thirds sorry right
so who have gone from atheism to um
theism so someone might say why why is
muslims would you hate that
but firstly what is atheism anyway like
it's not just not believing in god
because i idolatry in today's day and
age
isn't like idolatry and at the idolatry
of the past so obviously there are
people who still in this day and age
worship idols
but now people are worshiping money
people are worshiping power
so they'll spend all their time and
energy and effort
um dedicated to them to
increasing their power in this world
their money their wealth
or they worship women or they worship
drugs or they worship
something they're so even if they are an
atheist so to speak
they have taken their desires as their
god so the lost apparently
it says have they have you not seen one
who has taken their desires as they go
that's exactly what they've done
so they're going from one state of
disbelief to another it's not really a
an improvement so to speak because now
they've gone from worshipping many gods
in subtle ways to
actually worshiping many many gods or
venerating these entities
pretty directly so it's not really i
mean
it's not going to make any muslim happy
so that's not really an argument but
i've seen it
used quite a few times against muslims
who say yo don't take claims
dangerous because people want to find a
way out especially muslims they won't
speak about muslims
i think but muslims want to muslims are
curious because every human
is curious and if shaytan has planted a
seed in your mind
and you want to follow it you're going
to try and make 100 different excuses so
that you are able to follow that path
but if that's the case then you're not
submitting to allah you've already
submitted to your desires as well so
you need to also reflect on like those
it's like those people that smoke weed
and say nah man weed helps me think
about allah it helps me calm down and i
can pray better when i'm on it
but i'll get to that and we can get to
that later in trouble yeah so it's crazy
what ahmad was saying because it's
it's basically this new age stuff and
that's
that's their shot at uh replicating the
quran
like if you think about it the quran
says
allah says like uh try just
bring everyone together work together
and just try to bring something
remotely similar at least just one verse
remotely similar and they're over here
trying to like
break down what heaven means what hell
means
what god actually is and all this stuff
it's like
all right where are they getting this
you know now they just
are they pulling it out of their ass
because that's what it sounds like man i
mean
i could sit down and i could basically
allow my mind to like work its magic and
just
all these gears turning and come up with
this
crazy idea of like what god is and
and what the absolute life is and all
that stuff but it's like i can't claim
that
that i know it you know i can't claim
that like oh this is the truth
um 100 bro i can't wait till we go into
how it's related to jin
because a lot of people are like bro
this is jin series why are you guys
talking about psychedelics or
you know so brother khalil do you do you
want to share some studies today like do
you want a screen share or do you want
to just read them off
the screen show you how to get more
information yeah
i'll make you host if you uh as soon as
he's back you can we can
share some stuff but i was going to say
have you all ever felt for some
new age spirituality before at least
into dean if you all ever had a phase
where you weren't on dean
100 100 i mean that's how i uh
to be honest with you so i know like all
the stuff i know so
like that
i think you kind of have these parts
before you start practicing
if assuming you won like from when
you're a kid so
that specific path you learn from those
mistakes and then
you do things like this where you can
help other people learn from the same
mistakes you meet
but i think yeah i
especially in our day and age more more
people are going to fall into it
which is why normal podcasts and things
like this need to happen
because i'm sorry to interrupt the flow
but
yeah so we uh we we continued a little
bit bro we continued a little bit
nothing crazy but um
uh hallelujah he's basically saying it
right now as to um
yeah actually i i don't know but how do
i continue though
continue currently remember but i just
remember like
so we're gonna now link this back to
what does this have to do with
uh james so before we share a study uh
i just want to say for those who don't
know too much when you take dmt
the thing that most people report that
almost everyone reports if you take
enough
is that you believe this wall so you're
traveling through a tunnel your body
starts to become paralyzed almost so
it has no use you have to actually fight
the
the the experience to keep your eyes
open and to move your body
so the natural thing to do in that state
is to
just submit physically let alone
mentally if you don't mentally submit
you're also screwed because
then you're gonna literally feel like
you're in hell so
it's it's rough but notice that you
travel to another world
whether you actually travel or not
that's not what we're saying
that we don't know again it's kind of
like angel said
a couple episodes ago it's knowledge of
the unseen so maybe maybe not
who knows it's speculation at this point
but you travel somewhere
you feel like you're in some other place
and then you meet entities that's the
key pinnacle of the experience
what they look like who they are i'll
share that now so
when we look at the study the main thing
that the study focuses on is the
entities
so most of the data that they collected
was about how did the entity communicate
with you
um do i have sharing permissions
yeah i'm just gonna make you hoes yeah
so before you continue
um just reflect on that for a second
like when you take these substances
if you do not submit you go through hell
you experience like the worst experience
ever just just let that sink in
but if you submit then you have a nice
experience
it's a digital broad deception not only
that
usually the first few experiences are
sweet
and that it draws you in so you're being
pulled in now you're having these sweet
experiences you're like okay i'll let go
i'll let go i won't fight
and then you have these awesome
experiences there's usually people
around you encouraging you right this is
the culture now the cycle not culture
yeah man you got it you've got the flow
you've got the message
go back et cetera whatever i don't know
who's around you what kind of people are
around you but
you'll go back and you'll have all these
blissful experiences you now spread the
word
a couple years down the line this
happened with terence mckenna towards
the end of his life he had a mad crazy
experience in hawaii
he didn't trip like 10 years off so why
he had a mushroom trip that was so scary
to him that he didn't want a trip he's
still dedicating life his life to these
things but he couldn't
because he saw something that he didn't
want to go and see it yeah
so when they use you and they're done
with you and you've done their dirty
work for them
like they'll throw you
yeah before you screen share bro we had
a question from a patron who was
wondering
uh for ahmed how did you come up with
the name mr middle path
i have no idea this was a long time ago
and it just kind of rolled off the
tongue
i just thought you know what mr middle
path sounds like the best name and i
feel like it fits with
what islam is or what we're trying to be
we're all trying to be on the middle
path not too extreme this way not too
extreme that way
so i just thought what's the name and at
that time when i first started the
channel like what's the name that is
feel like it has some grounding and
islamic values but it's not
so in your face that non-muslims won't
want to watch the channel so i was like
you know what mr middle path seems like
a very good name
it's uh it's accessible to everybody
but at the same time it's based on
islamic principle
um
therefore we have made made you a middle
nation so that you can be
bear witness over all of the people and
that the prophets will bear witness uh
the prophet will bear witness over you
and uh
this goes in the day of judgment uh one
of the narrations
on the day of judgement certain people
will deny that they saw a prophet
or will deny that they had prophets come
to them and it'll be the muslims on the
day of judgment that will bear witness
for these prophets and say no
we know that these prophets came to
these people because our messenger told
us that you had
you had your prophet so even though we
didn't see those prophets allah has
given us that honor that we will bear
witness over the people as well
and um it also ties in with
that you are the best of people that
ever came out
why though because you enjoying good and
you forbid evil so there's that thing
that we have to do we enjoy good and for
good evil
and allah when he's talking about uh the
jewish people that were that were cursed
that they never they were cursed by
their own prophets
because they never used to see an evil
except that they didn't
most of the time didn't do anything
about it they just let it go so even the
good ones
or even the ones who were better
wouldn't stop the ones that were evil
from doing what they were doing it was
very rare only small groups of them
that would that would do that but the
majority of them whenever an evil was
done
they would just kind of let it slide
like oh why bother why try and change it
i talk to them about it but also i'm
saying about the muslim people that
you're the best nation because you
enjoying good and for good evil so that
ties in with mr
the whole mr middle path thing and also
the channels that we have like
all of us is to basically enjoying good
and forbid evil in a way
let me lift up the mic so the static
all prism i'll share this study now so
uh just just let me know when you can
see see the screen
there's a show yeah cool so
it's a little blurry no is it blurry
i'll zoom in maybe is that all right
yeah it's definitely that's better can
you zoom in a little more
yeah for sure for sure i don't know why
it looks like super blurry like i can't
even read anything
um it's it's not too blurry
it's actually there it
maybe it's just for my my computer but
yeah
i'm sure when it renders it will come
and clean if you guys it's clean it's
clean
all right perfect then okay so
uh in the green just is like it talks
about the methods of the study so 2561
people
by the way this is the biggest study
i've ever done this was done 2020 so
last year
it was an online survey about the most
memorable entity experience after taking
an end diameter tryptophan which is dmt
so if you see that just know that means
dmt in blue
this is the result in brief and we'll
just cover this off because we're not
going to read the whole study
but respondents report the primary
sensors involved in the encounter with
visual and extra sensory
or telepathic and the most common
descriptive labels for the entity were
being
guide spirit alien and helper so that
links to our last
last session although 41 percent of
respondents report
fear during the encounter the most
prominent emotions both in the
respondent and he attributed to the
entity with love kindness and joy
then most people endorsed that the
entity had the attributes of being
conscious
intelligent benevolent i.e they existed
they were real they weren't just
figure like uh figures of someone's
imagination they exist in some real but
different dimension of reality
again i mean look at these descriptions
and tell me what you have in mind as an
audience in the
chat but you know they continue to exist
after the encounter
so yeah respondents endorsed receiving a
message 69 a prediction about the future
19 and more than half who identified as
atheists before the experience no longer
identified as atheists after
the experience is what raita does among
the most meaningful spiritual
and psychologically insightful lifetime
experiences with persisting positive
changes in life satisfaction
purpose and meaning attributed to the
experiences
that's a that's a crazy paragraph uh and
a lot of could be spoken about just from
that and the conclusion of a study in
pink
was that dmt occasion entity encounter
experiences have many similarities
to non-drug entity encounter experiences
such as those
those described in religious alien
abduction and near-death contexts
and these experiences and its
interpretations produce profound
and enduring ontological changes in
world view so people
who looked at reality in one way all of
a sudden have completely
done a 180 flip the way they think about
the world
and the way it works and the meaning of
life etc so
yeah just just thought of the off the
bat of that what are you guys
thinking well it goes exactly with what
i was
stating prior and again it's crazy that
some people will even get to this point
and still write it off as just a
hallucination
yeah yeah for sure there's any way i can
see you guys videos
i also want people to pay attention to
where it says that it's very similar to
alien abduction and near-death context
so that was something we talked about in
the last video that
and trollo when brother goes forward
you'll see just the similarities between
the alien abduction experience and the
dmt
uh experience right we're gonna look
here now so this is the
descriptive labels for entities and i've
as you can see i've
like highlighted it in different colors
so blue being kind of
nice so being guide spirit alien helper
angel
these kind of come off as friendly and
these are the most common
and it says could select all that
applies so the percentages won't add up
to 100
but yeah that's just then there's the
pink
elf religious personage plant spirit
fairy chemical spirit animal spirit
look at the red mysterious yeah yeah the
red is where it's uh
kind of worrying and it's also
interesting that it's the least seen so
clown
demon no monster dead family member
devil unknown dead person dead friend
this a lot could be taken from this and
you can kind of maybe you can read in
some wisdoms and speculation but you
know how i said
in the beginning it will rope you in and
they'll seem friendly
that might be why all of this is and
then
as you get deeper and deeper it gets
more mysterious until it just straight
up messes with you and you start
entering into like some circus with
clowns and demons etc
um yeah i don't know what's going on
here
oh it's pause for a second so it's
basically
like that abusive relationship where
like people
who are abusive they'll come off as a
very friendly very loving at first and
then like the more
you interact with them the more closer
you get to them
the real colors start coming out and
then you start to see how abusive they
are but by the time you see this it's
almost always too late
and like you're kind of just stuck in
this abusive relationship with them
and oh man it's subhanallah it's almost
the same
with uh these entities with these gins
these genies
they are they can literally present
themselves as like
these uh blessed beings taking care of
you helping you guiding you
and then once you trust them allah
that's it
yeah i couldn't have put it better
myself to be honest they really do show
you
their true colors once the time comes
and then they'll just mess with you
and you're stuck not knowing what to
believe anymore because you spent so
long and invested so much time and
effort and energy into them
into the experience um
yeah what's that that was something that
uh john keel mentions in
one of the books uh operation trojan
horse
which we talked about in the last
episode where he said that it's
categorically when you look at these
mediums and spirit entities or whatever
whatever it is that they present
themselves to the people what they care
about
mainly is their message that you do the
message that they want you to do or
deliver the message that they want you
to deliver
so he says even the most kindest ones
if you can call it kindness but even the
ones that seem to be good
care more about the message and the act
the action that you're gonna do for them
then they care about you yourself
so and he gives examples of that uh
people that were mediums people that
were um
he gives this funny story of uh did i
tell you guys the story already
the story of the medium where he uh
he's channeling this entity and he's the
entity's always talking through him and
he's giving messages to his congregants
he was a christian pastor
and in the book he got sick so he tells
his friend look i want you to talk to
the medium and ask a question for me
so he's channeling the spirit into him
so that
the spirit or the not the spirit the
jinn can answer the question
that his friend will give him his friend
is asking about the pastor himself
so the pastor is sick and he's like okay
ask ask the spirit about
like my sickness and what i should do so
he channels the spirit
he channels the gin and the person's
like okay you know
your your host is sick you know what
should he do
and the gin snaps like well he better do
something because i can't work through
him much longer if he doesn't
that was it
so it just it just shows you like this
guy gave his body
for years and when he needed the entity
when he needed it then she was like f
you man you know do your mission and
shut up
it's pawn alone that just shows you what
it is
it's true man i mean some of these were
what we looked at before
so was it real was it not
and how that changed during the
experience versus after
uh where did it exist most said in some
real but different dimensional reality
some say in normal everyday physical
reality and kind of
people are kind of confused about that
one so you can see i was a bit
maybe they've been mixed most people
said it continued to exist off the
encounter
and it changed the way they saw reality
so yeah and these are
the kind of attributes or
characteristics of the entity only a few
said it was malicious 11
so really not that much but that's still
a significant amount
and it goes back to our previous point
eternals a lot of people
attributed to the divine characteristics
of them being eternal
to them being sacred benevolent
intelligent
so you can see how people put them
regardless of whether they say they
worship them
that's not even what we're getting at
now but they're saying they're secret so
they think they're holy
even if they're not religious that's
weird right that's where
again this is the atheist part agnostic
part so
most people started to believe in a
higher power so we have
you know i believe in ultimate reality
higher power god universal divinity
we've already spoken about why that's
not necessarily here
i think that muslims will celebrate and
it's not a reason at all for people to
take this
as a muslim and yeah well maybe that'll
be the last thing we speak about muslims
in dmt
but what we need to realize is dmt
has a deep history so its history is in
ayahuasca and we'll speak about that
after we look at this study
just to understand how that links back
to magic and why this is so dangerous
uh these are open-ended responses so
people wrote a message uh
so for example love love is the answer
to everything
verbatim so we've said that a few times
maybe in this podcast or
you know love is the answer to
everything no that's literally what they
say so this is one of the highest
ranking
messages that were received um our
purpose is to love each other
this one's crazy right so the task or
command
given was worship me
that it says that and this is john
hopkins university this is a very
reputable
in fact one of the most reputable
studies on dmt that i've come across
and this is what is said to people
worship me
like what
man oh no oh no look
shook right now oh i didn't know y'all
could see me bro
i can't see you i'm trying to like look
i'm trying to like you know go closer to
see it
can you not interrupt can you remind us
of the study
they were looking at the most positive
experience or the most memorable dmt
experience
yes the idea was the most almost
memorable yeah
yeah it doesn't necessarily a memorable
entity encounter it doesn't necessarily
mean it was the most positive
uh and that's one of the limitations of
the study in the sense that it's
memorable but there may be some
less memorable ones that were far more
traumatic and the idea of these studies
by the way
when we look take a step back and look
at it from a bigger picture perspective
kind of similar to what i was saying in
the beginning they want to start using
these things
to treat depression they want to start
using these things to treat these
illnesses
and the only way they're going to do
that is through research because you
can't just start administering drugs you
need
facts behind you so you need surveys
like this and so they're going to want
to try and capitalize
on the positive experiences people have
and so
that's a limitation for the study but
it's also a bad is bad news because
they want the results to be good so they
don't want to have many percentages of
the entities being malicious because
they want to
make use of these things and eventually
make money out of it as well
so there's a lot there's a lot to it
it's not just more than oh we want to
help people
people aren't that good my bad for
interrupting you but
no i'm looking at this now and i'm
looking at the percentages
and it's saying that 11 got to the point
where
it was basically was basically saying
worship me
like that was a task and then uh i guess
below it says
um do not tell anyone about this
and then the safety and assurance it
told me that everything was okay i was
being reassured that i was safe
bro bro the whole worship me like
think about it 11 but that would
actually be higher
if the people kept going with these uh
psychedelics because a lot of times when
people do have these experiences
um they may have like several more after
and then just
they're pretty much done you know what i
mean like they're not uh they're not
doing it anymore
just trying to check something here but
do it with that
like i think the people who kept going
who kept taking
the psychedelics they're the ones that
experienced the point where
uh the entity finally shows its true
colors and it twists and now it's saying
worship me
so that's that's scary you you made a
good point that i forgot to mention
some people think that if someone was to
only have two dmt experiences then
that's
rookie numbers oh that's nothing i know
someone who's smokes like two joints a
day and does
this and that and drinks every night no
no you can't compare them because
one dmt by nature and most likely if not
all
anti-addictives you take and you don't
want to take it again for a while
because it's so
intense so if someone's done it more
than 10 20 30 40 times
you know they're serious about it and
that's when it gets dark so
yeah like you said if they carry on it
gets crazy uh but most people only do it
a few times not everyone i've met who's
done it
as has said probably one to five
in terms of the number of times we've
done the mta i haven't met that many
people
i actually haven't met anyone else who
said more than five so on on a side note
like
um there's actually a very there's a
process that people can go through
that allows them to um basically
decalcify
their pineal gland whether
decalcification or decalcification and
calcification even occurs in the pineal
gland
that's up for debate some people believe
it some people don't but there are
things that you can do
that will literally bring you like your
body to produce more dmt
and i remember i started doing this with
the sole intention of
experiencing more and look bro look how
ignorant i was all right look how
enjahed i was but i did it because i
wanted to
feel like i was on a shroom trip all the
time
and uh i remember i experienced
something
that was so crazy that i was like yeah
no i don't want to do this anymore
yeah yeah yeah i know you mean as well
like
you choose the right toothpaste on the
right water and then yeah you end up
going through all of these processes
all for what most people before they
take these things especially ayahuasca
they'll fast
you won't think much of that but if you
add it all up like i was saying in the
beginning you'll fast you'll travel
you'll have an intention the word
intention is hardly ever used
for anything else except for spiritual
things and yes
i mean like there's a there's a reason
why so
you you take a step back like even if
you read through the study i'll i'll
just finish
this point even if you read the study
and you're not muslim it kind of
you'll kind of be confused you read it
with islam through the lens of islam and
it
completely cuts through it and you're
able to see it completely without any
doubts
and you're able to pick like pick
everything out and understand it and
know what is what it's all about because
you have that perspective that islam
gives you
yeah 100 don't feel rushed either bro
don't feel rushed i
i'm uh i've been interrupting a lot
lately so
please don't feel rushed um
but i will say that
uh when you when you're mixed in with
this when you're doing the whole pineal
gland declassification when you're doing
actual projection when you're doing all
this stuff um something that's very
heavily linked with it
is uh this whole idea of the third eye
and that the pineal gland is the third
eye and that um
you need to open your third eye and uh
when i was doing this i'm not gonna lie
to you guys i was doing
the natural stuff which if you think
about it the natural stuff
the natural stuff seems fine like
doing more natural toothpaste drinking
less fluoride
eating more organic whole foods this is
fine
but then when it's linked with oh we
need to
decalcify the pineal gland so we can
activate it so we can open the third eye
well that's when
it becomes a problem because then now
you're doing something with a different
intention like you said the intention
matters the most here so yeah bro i'm
not going to interrupt you anymore i'll
let you i'll let you go in
that was good
just like how you shared your thoughts
about you know the person the being
saying uh worship me
look at these red highlights here and
tell us your thoughts on that inshallah
what's on the page right now yeah yeah
so there's the two
main ones the prediction about the
future so someone thought about missing
zippo later for some reason
and the entity flashed it to them where
it was and then after he came back to
came back when he says come back he
means uh he came back to this world this
dunya
he went to that spot deep inside the
couch and grabbed it perfectly it was
unreal
um and then another one the second one
is i was essentially told that i was god
or it gave me some information that said
that this being i.e the entity was in
service of god
so yeah what are your thoughts
damn that's a lie
listen i'll tell you i'll tell you this
right now okay so i've been wanting to
say this the entire podcast
so i actually yeah bro i'm hyped i'm
hyped to say this right now
so first off before i say let me let me
preface this
and have ahmed jump in here so ahmed
you had spoken about the barriers
all right why don't you kind of touch
basis on that in terms of like what the
barriers are
and um what we do that can
basically reduce these barriers and what
happens when these barriers are reduced
so ultimately what and again
here we go bro these these gyms are
working hard bro
yeah everything everything he does
mentioned though will be from i think it
was from a call we had with him right i
don't know
about just the barriers between us
all right i'm sorry guys but in islam
before we eat we say before we go into
the bathroom
uh we stay certain of god even before
intercourse with our spouse
so god for everything literally
everything to
uh protect us from the shayateen being
present or for or even joining us in
anything
so magic very much in any of its forms
is the opposite of that
you're basically inviting them in
whether you know you're doing it or not
but you're inviting them in so that's
that's what we mean when we say barriers
it's any activity that you're doing
and you're invite that invites jin into
your life instead of the opposite which
is what islam teaches is you're blocking
them from
from from affecting you or from doing
any harm to you
so yeah so psychedelic drugs or whatever
that
whatever that branch is right whether
it's a yoga and
we'll get into yoga on another episode
inshallah because
uh it's very similar to what we're
reading here
whatever that branch of magic is
basically you're you're what you're
doing is you're inviting them into your
life you're willingly saying come
you know so that let me know let me know
if uh
let me know if any of you all can relate
to this this whole barrier that you're
saying goes down when we
do drugs or psychedelics i feel like me
personally when i sleep it really lowers
that barrier at times
you guys know what i mean there before
we sleep
there's a lot of utkar that we say
before we go to bed
so many you know courtesy you can say
you're you're three
coins three times
then you have the dot before you go to
bed two uh bismuth
that whole that whole dua so there's so
many at god that you say and
there is even a book it's called
fortress of the muslim like literally
fortress of the muslim this is full of
god in the
in the in the morning until the night
prophet muhammed tells us
if you say this wicked from in the
morning
uh that that the the like jin or like to
the sheraton can't affect you until the
evening so what happens in the evening
you say that they could again
so you're consistently remembering allah
is protecting you from
all of this evil whereas you know
obviously with the magician
he's doing the opposite he's saying
please you know come more of you i'll
i'll
i'll accept i'll talk to you whatever
he's whatever that that person
is intending whether they realize it or
not simply by not doing the afkar
we're weakening ourselves to this type
of influence uh not just
uh jinn but also hassa right someone can
give you evil eye
right someone can have envy for you so
what does what is what is the one of the
shortest surahs easiest
to
remember
from the evil of the whispers of
all all of these are seeking refuge i
seek refuge in allah from
shaytan i seek refuge in allah from the
whispers of shaytan i seek refuge and
love from evil people
so someone who's constantly doing this
is going to be protected and prophet
muhammad says that you're going to be
protected
you know one reflection i have on there
oh oh sorry i thought you were like no
no no go ahead
okay i was just going to say kind of
reminds me of how we have
so i'm in a best when speaking about
ayat and spoke about how
uh we have different scene angels
assigned to us so
some that are there to write our deeds
somehow that whisper good some are there
to protect us
from the front and the back for example
um there's like
like um muhammad was saying that's a
girl you can read or recite before going
to sleep
and allah sent an angel to protect you
that night there's a reason why because
i have experienced that when i haven't
um
done any girl i've forgotten or
something and i'm slipping into sleep
i have like it gets weird like it gets
really weird and you have like
experiences that are trippy and that you
may see entities and you may see
these shadows or if you have speed
paralysis then
that's a whole nother layer and this
will probably like tease the next
episode because
it's similar to i had a i had a very
good friend of mine who used to be
involved in sufism before he got out
and uh i want to talk about sufism in
another episode inshallah i'm not
knocking on my sufi brothers and sisters
in islam you know you i love you all for
the sake of allah
i'm talking about certain tariffs and
certain activities that some sufis do
you know but he was involved in that
when he got out he would experience and
even before he got out he would
experience
like jin dreams and weird things like
that he would not
notice that when he did not say his he
did not
uh or when he forgot to say his that he
would experience weird dreams or
certain types of the general and i've
had multiple friends who have had
jin try to attack them in their dreams
but alhamdulillah allah protected them
so the jinn was unable to attack them in
the dream
and they woke up and like yo man this
was this is actually a big one i've had
um someone i know that was
and i don't want to say this actually i
don't want to say what the dreams were
but ultimately
we say are with god to protect us from
those things and then they cannot harm
you
so because allah tells us that they
can't do any the magician can't do
anything
without the permission of allah and in
nike the shaytani kind of
cannot be that the plotting of shaytan
is actually quite weak
you know it's we that accept if you
think about magic what is it
it's you accepted the invitation
that's what it is it's not that the jin
just came and forced himself on you no
you accepted that he can come you signed
the agreement you
by by you gave your consent ultimately
by taking the drug you gave your consent
so they came if you didn't give your
consent they can't come
and what magic is the reason that magic
is able to
circumvent that you're able to hurt
somebody else the jinn couldn't do it on
his own
he needed a human being to consent in
order for that jinn to attack another
human
that's why the penalty for them for
people doing magic is death
in islam uh and there was actually one
story of uh
i forget this was during the umayyad
dynasty one of the kings was listening
to an astrologer
so one of the sahabas was still alive in
that time he brought his sword with him
the astrologer was giving his
predictions and he cuts off his head in
front of the the king because why'd you
do that you know i didn't i didn't
tell you it was like look man he said
he's a magician and he can have he has
all these powers
well let him put his head back on if he
can't do that then he's not a magician
so the king got angry and threw him in
prison but
but with that sword strike he basically
showed everyone that this man
is a liar and i i think i i want to talk
about that in the yoga episode because
some of the powers that yoga
yogis say that they have is that they
can be revived after death
they can live after death they have the
power of immortality
and so forth and when you look at some
of the stories that they have
actually i'm jumping ahead of myself
let's save that for the for the yoga
episode inshallah but
ultimately um magic is not as strong as
people
uh think it is you know allah
that the weakest of the of the houses is
the spider's house
right and if we look at what's what's a
powerful magic also
i forget the exact air but they
basically came with great magic the
pharaoh the pharaohs magicians they
threw their
yeah they threw their sticks and they
threw their ropes and they
placed cast magic on the eyes of the
people and the people
believed that they saw snakes wriggling
and that this was actually great magic
so what was the great magic
hallucinating giving people the illusion
that they saw snakes
comparing that to an actual miracle
where musa is stick and it became a real
snake like an actual real snake
so we see that magic is a very cheap
imitation
of what the prophets can do right and
what miracles are that magic is just a
cheap imitation of that
and who were the first people to believe
in musa it was the magicians they saw
them like yo this is not magic
this is a real miracle we believe in
musam and we believe in the god of moses
and pharaoh killed them because because
he was he got he got very angry about
that but they saw that reality they
realize that they're like there's no way
and they also said that we we repent and
we turn
back from this magic that you forced us
to do so even
even the magicians didn't like being
magicians they they blamed pharaoh and
said you forced us to do this magic you
you made us get involved in this
lifestyle we don't like it we hate it
so that says a lot that that story is a
very powerful story in the quran
[Music]
i mean one of the benefits that people
take from this story is that
they were supposed to be the best
magicians at the time and
yet when they came face to face with a
true prophet who wasn't using magic
but they claimed it was magic right if
iran claimed that he was doing magic
he beat them at their own game and so
that's why they all accepted islam so
when we're talking about all these
things we realize that islam will
not any explanation of these entities
out of the water
and so when people usually hear about it
and people who muslims who have or
people who aren't muslim take the mt and
then they hear the islamic position
oftentimes they do come to islam i'm not
saying dmt is a good thing and
actually i'm just going to share screen
one more time just to show why it's so
bad
just to wrap this kind of like part up
about
why it's so evil so let me know if you
can see this clearly in trouble
i'm gonna take a second yeah
zoom in
how's that yeah that's much better
but it'll render in a second it takes a
little bit to run
no worries but the the kind of point of
just sharing this is
let me speak about ayahuasca now
ayahuasca is an ancient brew that has
been used for thousands of years and the
main active ingredient is dmt
right and there are actually two
ingredients one which is the dmt and the
other which is an
maoi inhibitor m-a-o-i or
s-m-a-o-i sorry monoamine oxidase
inhibitor
now when you normally have dmt's found
in plants by the way it's found in
human beings it's found in plants it's
found in animals it's far throughout
nature
but normally when you eat a salad for
example you're not going to trip on dmt
because your
stomach has natural enzymes to break it
down so it will never enter your
bloodstream
however somehow
these shamans from
thousands of years ago knew to combine
the these two can you guys hear me
okay cool yeah they knew they knew to
combine these two plants one which was
rich in
maois and one was which was rich in dmt
how they knew well their explanation was
the plants told us all the plant spirits
told us which doesn't make any sense if
you don't believe in spirits
that it makes sense if they already had
some sort of connection with these gym
and what they wanted to do was then
progress that connection to now see them
and
interact with them more and get to know
them so
this is a type of magic which is why
doing dmt is extremely dangerous
and here it talks about how magic has
been
defined by many ways so there's some
which is which is words said by
magicians and knots which affect the
heart and body
leading to sickness and or death or
separating husband and wife these are
some
symptoms or some use cases negative use
cases
and then there's two main types there's
a magic which is not
this type is this type is done with the
help of shayateen by worshipping them so
they can provide the services to their
miseration
this type of shirk so it's you want to
be the worst crime you can commit
and whoever practices it is no longer
muslim so if you're almost in beforehand
let's say you've notified yourself
dangerous dangerous stuff
which is why no muslim should ever
approach these things
not even as a joke and the second type
is like look at this magic used by herbs
and medicine plant medicine right that's
literally what it is
herbs and medicine plant medicine and
this may have some effect on people's
vision
there is dispute amongst the scholars
whether this type of magic
um so
whether it's
um and there's and the rest of this goes
into the difference of opinion but i
just want to share that to show
look this this isn't a joke and dmt
isn't just this fun thing i wanna try
and then see what i see and see what i
experience as a muslim and see if it
increases my iman
you're not gonna get a piece of paper
say i'm gonna laminate this piece of
paper
and put that piece of paper in a
shredder because that wouldn't make any
sense
and there is a strong punishment against
the magician like i had said because
it's so dangerous
one of the use cases like we just read
was breaking and this is the use case in
the quran is breaking a husband from his
wife
so what is a magician doing except
breaking society apart what's so
beautiful about islam is
on an individual level it purifies on a
family level um it on a family level it
unifies
and on a societal level it helps them it
guides them all to the divine
so it creates this beautiful system
where the whole nation is in servitude
to allah
magician breaks up the family it poisons
the hearts of the individuals
and society is now in disarray once you
break the family and you guys will know
this once you break the family and you
add all these ideologies which try and
remove the family and remove the father
figure and the heart of the wife
etc the mother that's it's over
right because now society's crumbling
and we're seeing that now with our own
eyes so
the magician isn't to be taken lightly
and so such a crime
even though dmt may seem harmless what
does that lead to
people start doing more practices it's
only a stepping stone to something even
worse
it was cinnamon itself but you can see
why it's so dangerous so
the main message is don't do it i don't
even think about doing it because that's
a seed planted by shaytan
protect yourself without the cow and
protect yourself mentally and islam is
way better would you sell
a bit of pleasure in this dunya which is
it may feel like
infinite but it it isn't it's a few
minutes dmt is five minutes goes a
couple hours a few hours
would you sell that for infinite
pleasure
for infinite time in general who would
who who sane would do that so
yeah that's that's my random i think i
want to i want to throw in a question
unless angel you have a question you
want to throw in first
i spoke a lot so i'ma let you go in all
right so
the question is and remember one of the
subscribers to your
channel the three muslims podcast they
were asking okay well what about
um law of attraction and what about the
secret and all this so those people say
oh but that's black magic this is
this is white magic so what would be the
response
then for those who genuinely believe i'm
not mocking anyone i just i just think
it's funny because of you know when you
see what you see
then you know how how um
uh how deceptive this this argument
isn't but i'm not making fun of anyone
because you know everyone
a lot of people have been there where
they genuinely do get deceived and
confused so
what would you say then to those say oh
yeah but that's black magic what about
white magic what about law of attraction
what about these things
what you're what you're doing well
regardless of the time you're gonna
use is the same thing there's no it's a
nice way of trying to differentiate oh
this is bad and this is good i can take
it's like having trying to have your
slice and either you know you're trying
to have your
slice of the cake i need it you can't do
the like the
the same thing uh the practice
is evil by default so there's no
there's no concession because if we
start opening up the door to
just this part why what's the what's the
real difference
so then you open the door to x but not y
well that's that's a that's hypocrisy so
people are then going to pursue
y because x is good and y is for some
reason
black but the more they learn about it
the more they realize this one same
thing has the same origins back in
history
so there's no such thing as white and
black it's all
just magic we don't say black magic and
then white magic
that no one says that um it's a crime
it's a crime and the
the idea of lord law of attraction is is
by default shirk and it's used by
magicians
um it's used by magicians and it's a
form of empowering the universe in a
sense we make dua we trust
allah we don't we don't
put our wants and wills out into the
universe and hope that it will manifest
we put it into dua and we trust in
hunger so it's
i don't i don't really know too much
about the law of attraction it's kind of
like it's kind of like
nature worship in a sense you're sending
out your desires to the universe and
then the universe fulfills your
your desires and if you so there's a lot
to it but ultimately it's so
what they're asking you to do is shikh
right when you send your desire out to
the universe
and they have weird things like oh i
spoke i can speak my reality into
existence and then i can work to
achieve whatever my so all of these
things are very shirky it's basically
putting the human being
in the place of god or saying that oh
these are certain laws that if you do
them
you're bound to have success and this
idea is also in that in the book by
napoleon hill think and grow rich very
very popular book especially
entrepreneurs love to read oh yeah think
and grow rich has the best book ever
but it's the same thing as the theory of
the law of attraction right
you send your thoughts out to the
universe or you will your own reality
into existence
so it's basically replacing man with god
and it's very similar to to to these
pagan ideologies
if you look i remember when i was
reading the napoleon hill book there was
one thing that
really caught that really went whoa and
i don't have the book with me right now
but i do remember this very vividly when
they were talking about
people who are poor it's their fault for
being poor
because they didn't try hard enough the
ones who are successful
they willed it they believed in
themselves so it's your fault if you're
poor and this is just what the kuffar
said
in mecca when allah to donate money to
the poor they said
should we give money to those whom allah
could have given uh
risk to like why should we give money
why should we give charity to the poor
and it's a very arrogant way of thinking
too that oh i did this just like um
just like arun and and uh and
from beni is so much wealth that even
people who were
holding his keys had difficulty holding
his keys he needed an army of men to
hold his keys to his world not just the
wealth itself
so that's how rich he was and he said i
got this from my own cleverness
this is from me right and allah caused
the earth to swallow him up
so it's just a form of arrogance
ultimately
and the reason it ropes people in is
because they take certain
elements of religion and put it into
their books
so that it can be palatable to those who
believe in religion
i say oh yeah my religion teaches
something like this oh i can do this
practice because it doesn't go against
my faith it's just
it's just a certain um way of thinking
but when you dig deeper into it it's not
a certain way of thinking it's it's this
very specific unique way of thinking of
that goes outside of what the dean tells
you to do my mic
is actually working on let me meet
myself yeah bro i can't be the only one
that
wants to ask you guys you know what does
music have to do with this where does
music
chime into this i i can
maybe like share a couple of thoughts so
music is
you know how some people speak about
music as being food for the soul
they're not i i wouldn't say that too
far from the truth but i won't call it
food because food
implies nourishment it's more
intoxication so
it reaches into the soul and it and it
makes it feel a certain way and it
changes the way you think and it changes
the way you feel
however i'm a scholar of islam
um he had this really cool analogy
where he speaks about actually i won't
even use that one he had another one
which
he said very simply that the
quran and music cannot exist in the same
heart
so they'll have to fight it out and one
will win over the other
and it's almost a symbolism of are you
going to choose the path of
allah or the path of shaykh so though it
may not seem bad
and most and the vast majority of
scholars have
have forbidden music with musical
instruments for a reason
um based on the quran and sayings of the
sahaba etc
there's a reason why because it's the
tool of shaytan
is something that he uses to reach into
your heart
so if your heart is not occupied with
the quran
something else is going to take that
place there's a reason why people listen
to music it makes them feel good it
makes them feel a certain way
it puts them in a certain vibe but the
quran nothing can replace it
and that should be our goal and so you
can think of it
as a symbolism for how you want to live
your life uh look at the end part look
at the goal
think of life as a mountain i'll get
into this
in the next episode and show how i try
and live my life in this kind of
picture and how i try and walk towards
things
to make sure that i stay islamic in my
decisions
but the point is that's the kind of
analogy that i've liked the best
and in terms of how it leads to sin
that's quite clear
look at lyrics in today's danish look at
lyrics
uh in any kind of song whether it's a
love song and someone's attributing
their heart to someone else
like you my heart belongs to you what
does that mean
right or whether it's talking about more
you know basic things like money and
love and drugs etc
so women etc so it's gonna lead us
in um it's gonna lead it's not to lead
to
good bro i don't i don't want to speak
for the choir but this is just for my
life
my life didn't really get on dean until
i stopped music
you know what i mean like i thought i
was on beam i was still getting that
feeling that you get
annoyed or like kind of like people that
smoke cigarettes and quit quit after a
while the smell of cigarettes is nasty
you get that feeling when you hear music
like it's kind of like annoying
honda i couldn't even drive without
music or you know now it's like
they've been months man it's like i
really feel undeed
you know i i do want to say something
very important that
even way before the time of the prophet
muhammed and amongst non-muslim
societies it was well known that music
even without lyrics change your mental
state so this was written in plato's
republic
socrates is talking about this and
plato's republic when um
not socrates in plato's republic plato
is the one who is they're talking about
what's the ideal republic do they uh do
they ban music or do they let music be
allowed
and there's other books on different
habits like archery versus music which
is the best these are classical books
right
so they note that uh stringed
instruments
makes men soft and womanly and in
um allows one to have womanly qualities
that's strength instruments specifically
drums makes someone more war-like
and i forgot what the flute and wind
instruments do but
string instruments they have the story
of
for example plato plato and plato's
republic says we're going to ban string
instruments but we're going to allow the
drums
and in another story you have the
emperor of persia i forget which one he
wanted to conquer certain people that
were very warlike so he said okay let's
change their culture first before we
conquer them let's introduce our
musicians and our strength instruments
in
and try to have them change their
culture such that the men wear
longer skirts instead of pants right
once we get them to change their culture
in that way then we can conquer them
it'll be easy and that's exactly what
happened
the string instruments became the
fashion uh
the fashion of clothing changed from
skirts from long pants to skirts and
then the emperor said
all right now it's time let's get at it
right let's conquer these people
and you have this you know in the
ancient books like these are ancient
works and it's been said that if
two civilizations that never contacted
each other reached the same conclusion
it's it it would be wise to pay
attention to what's
to what they're saying so string
instruments were known
to make men soft and they're prohibited
for that reason for
for most war-like war-like countries
didn't like
for the same reason they didn't like
weed because it turns men into
uh for one of a better word uh soft
pussycats you know
they're not gonna go to war they're not
gonna take action they're not gonna get
up they're not gonna do what they need
to do
weed and string instruments um is the
piano
a stringed instrument it is isn't it
yeah it is
because it's it's like a mix of
percussion and string right yeah yeah
yeah so it's going to turn
prophet muhammad saw them from what we
understand the death was the only
permissible one and on certain occasions
the death was a type of wide uh thin
drum
and you couldn't really play the same
rhythm on the def that you can with a
regular drum
you know the one that makes you get up
and dance and so forth also
to note uh prophet shithare salam
was one of the sons of adam after habib
passed away a prophet sheet and i
recommend people to look into the lives
of the prophet stories
uh very important uh prophet chief allah
he was trying to call to allah to the
people that had gone astray
at this time human history was still
very young
so shirk hadn't really happened yet but
shaytan came in the form of of a human
being
right so these were the descendants of
paavir that she was trying to
um talk to to become muslim these were
the ones who
were with prabhir and shaytan came in
the form of a human being
and basically said let me play music for
you guys this is to the people of
pavilio
and what was the instrument that he
played he played a flute or a type of
wind instrument
right and that got the people dancing
that got the people partying
uh that led to zina and prophet would
prevent his people from going over there
and some people didn't want to listen to
him and they'd go over there to party
with the
with the uh with the uh what's it called
with
with the woman there right so the people
from that were descended from kabil had
very ugly men but beautiful women
yeah people descended from the people
descended from habil had very
handsome men but the women were not as
as beautiful as the people
so what happened when they went over is
the the crime of zina started happening
again
the crime of [ __ ] hadn't really started
yet because it was still early in human
history
although some people say that shaitan
came in the form of a human being and
and somehow to start worshiping fire
right this is i've heard this from
scholars before but
to know that the wind instrument was the
one that was
being uh selected by shaitaan and you
see this theme right like in
in europe you have the pied piper
playing the
playing that wind instrument to lure the
kids away from
their parents or from their homes so
these musical instruments
well understood that they had certain
abilities to uh
seduce the senses seduce the minds of
men it's used
by cults and by you uh by
certain tariffs and certainly in worship
right to get to a certain state they'll
use music to enhance that
uh that's that ecstasy or that spiritual
high that they want to achieve
you know
as for whether musical instruments are
held or not some
scholars would say that okay it's okay
as long as it's remembering allah
subhana wa ta'ala
or as long as the lyrics are gonna
remember allah but as far as we know the
majority of
scholars were on the opinion that
nasheeds which is just vocals
and poetry as long as the lyrics are
okay that's what was
considered to be acceptable but the
musical instrument itself even if you
take out the horrible lyrics the musical
instrument itself
still has a massive effect on your
psyche and your state of mind
which is why it's to be avoided and this
was understood by non-muslim cultures
throughout history as well how powerful
musical instruments could be i wanted to
touch on that
story bro so they were like a group of
like the first one had like the
attractive men and
non-attractive women then the other one
had unattractive uh
men but attractive women and then after
the music was introduced and they
started you know free mixing and all
that
i believe it was the attractive men
started you know mating with the
attractive women right and then vice
versa they like intermingled between the
two groups
they were parting together they came
they came because of the music
you know so subhanallah and uh
shaytaan coming in human form is
something that i want to talk about in
the in
the next episode but to bring it back to
the topic itself brother khalid if you
could show
the um
the highlight the red highlight again to
the messages that the entities gave
but i think that's very important that
ties in that's that ties in with the
previous episode of aliens
and it's going to tie in with the next
episode of yoga and so forth
so yeah i did have a question too
in terms of huh throw it in
that's that's what i'm doing it's my
love
this one now so you were saying the
musical instruments how there's uh
there's one that of which is permissible
i think it's uh
it's the arabic dramas but what they're
called the what def def and it's
it's it's a very wide thin drum it's
very difficult to do any type of like
actual music on it it's just a very
simple doom
and they'd play that in weddings or
something so okay so
what what would be the difference
between that
and um like have you ever heard like war
drums
where it's like there's really there's
not rhythm like dancing i will say i
don't know
honestly i'm going to say i don't know
you know i've i've i've heard like
what you're speaking about wardrobes
actually i can't remember when it was it
was eight years ago so
no one called me on this and no one act
on this but i did read a photo
which spoke about specifically at the
time of battle one poetry should be used
to encourage the fighters to raise their
spirits and
they cite some evidence and the same
thing they said if
if a instrument was to be used then the
only one that would be permissible would
be the
the the drums of war don't call me on
this and don't
act on this i mean unless you're
involved and even then don't just do
your own research
basically those those wide thin drums
oh yeah let's not let's not go into it
if we don't know i i do want to say that
those little drums that they play in the
parties the arab ones they go
like those are really fast you can't you
can't do that on a def
like you can't actually do that it's
very very difficult so it's not used for
that
i got you well i mean it's all kind of
registering very clearly
because if you think about it like
imagine you're going to war
and then they're playing like piano
music
like it just wouldn't work you wouldn't
be hyped up
um i had when i was a personal trainer i
had a client
and he told me that um he used to play
rugby
and when he would play rugby his uh
coach
would have this drum and then he would
just start beating this drum
and he would go around the players and
he would actually change the rhythm
whenever he would get to certain players
just to see their reactions and he said
that whenever he would
find a rhythm that would cause the the
player to
almost get irritated like start getting
angry he would continue that rhythm just
like keep hyping them up even more and
it worked
like it worked they said that they would
go into games and it's like they were
out for blood and they would win
every single game so it's crazy that you
guys said
that the drums was basically like a war
it has the warlike characteristics
increases that
and the uh the string and the wind
instruments they increase the feminine
qualities because like that's something
that i knew
is that the piano will lower
testosterone
so it is crazy yeah i've heard some
initiate which
have the drama in the background to like
maximize
lyrics and i've heard you know what i
remember when my cousin was like hey
listen to this
i was like oh this is good and he's like
okay this is the drum but i'll say what
you feel like something i don't know
what it is you get that
that drive i wouldn't recommend it but
that is what it is you know know i don't
want anyone to misunderstand what we're
saying and say oh
they said all we can listen to drums
it's not what we're saying consult with
your local imam and your scholar about
what
to do because you know we're not
scholars you know we're not qualified
yeah you follow a particular method
follow that and
ask your scholars about that we're we're
talking about this from a historical
point of view
that's just really what we're saying
trying to give you the argument that
music affects your psyche which is
ties in with the psychedelic and the new
age culture because very much so they
use
music to enhance certain states of mind
that's what we're trying to say people
so please don't misunderstand us
disclaimer yeah sure
sir you wanted me to share this remember
remember the second yeah remember the
second
uh row so we had the red that said
worship me but then when we go down a
little bit
it's there's the other one that said he
is in the service of god or whatever
right we can go before i do that i just
remembered in our video we didn't
actually cover this which is
kind of funny because we're supposed to
be comprehensive but i missed it
here right underneath it talks about the
similarities of dmt entity encounter
experiences to descriptions of non-drug
the encounter experiences i won't read
it but
this this is a huge part of the study
like needs a lot about this
so we didn't we just didn't
we did cover this because they um they
didn't go over as deeply as we wanted
to go over so we had to look into other
books and stuff but that's true
if you go up if you go up um yeah
a little bit just to that red part so
for example stop right there
um they told me um hold on one second
yeah so this is going to be a clear
distinct divide and a restructuring of
society
with you come on come on feedback i
think we got that static oh okay here my
bad
perfect can you can you zoom in a little
bit because i have to lean in to attack
you
oh yeah where was the thing about the
lighter
that's up here what's up here okay so
you see this here there's going to be a
clear and distinct divide between if you
if you scroll back up
just a little bit i'm sorry i want to go
to the lighter yeah there's going to be
a clear distinct divide and
restructuring of society with the
assistance of et consciousness
so that one right there the one that
you're looking at right now the top one
i mean that's exactly what i talked
about in the previous
video with the aliens coming in and
talking to people
so how on earth is someone taking dmt
why are they going to another planet so
this is again proving what those authors
in the past book were talking about that
this is not something extraterrestrial
this is something here on earth
because whether it's a spaceship coming
from
sky or whether someone's taking a drug
you have an entity saying
saying the exact same thing uh if we go
up to the
to the lighter thing right this was also
mentioned in the previous
uh video where they would give some
information to prove that they were an
authentic being
that and to try and wow you into
following them
so the same thing even with the alien
contact he experiences
people would have something similar to
this right it's very random
why does an alien care about where your
lighter is on the couch if it was really
extraterrestrial
so if we go down a little bit to where
it says
uh they are god um or even here i will
die in my 60s from something i can
prevent i was told that the day i'm
going to die is june 27 2067
so remember what we talked about on the
previous video about ufo cults
where they give these types of
predictions to make people believe
so all of these messages from dmt
entities
are very similar to the messages that we
talked about in the ufo entity encounter
experiences even though those people
didn't take dmt
they never took dmt this is them seeing
the alien coming to them
or uh or it's an alien abductee or
contact
experience whatever it was that we
talked about in the previous video but
this is very similar
messages right and when we go into the
next episode on yoga
it's also going to be very similar
messages where yoga was
some historians dispute whether it's 4
000 or 6 000 years ago that these type
of practices started but
however the case is you have this
connection and this similar theme in
these messages
between people that go into yoga people
that do dmt
people that think that they're talking
to aliens so
again this is proving that these
phenomena are all one and the same and
it's coming from the world of the gym
this is what we're trying to say
and thanks for trying it together yeah
so the last thing
i think this would be a good close out
here um
it's the thing i've been waiting to say
the entire podcast
yeah so um remember how i asked you to
talk about the uh the barriers yeah and
all that
yeah so essentially before i even say
that
i'm just speaking on this whole barrier
thing i forgot to say is but fire when
you said that you go to sleep
and you feel like the barrier is lowered
at that point i feel like if you wake up
from your sleep like let's say you're
about to go to the bathroom or something
your barrier is real low because like i
don't know about you guys but
you know sometimes sometimes i i
experience some things when i'm like
i i gotta start praying and everything
in order to like
i guess you could say bring the barrier
back up no no when you wake
up from your sleep like in the middle of
the night or something like that
and that's a time when your barrier is
real low but
i guess i'm not that's not what i'm
trying to say here so if we're talking
about the barriers
all right think about this okay it could
happen when you take a psychedelic it
could
have been doing anything else in your
life but primarily this happens when you
take psychedelics because this
it makes you submit to the psychedelic
all right now when you submit to it
and whatever this thing is the the
entities
and you already know the other genies
right we know
we know this thing will basically
present nothing but good right very good
characteristics
it'll say ah like i am a servant of god
or
i am a helper i am all this stuff okay
it starts like that and it gives you
like we were talking about gives you a
good experience it gives you something
good
where it's like you start to open up
more and more and once you're fully
open to it well now i can give you 99
lies
and you're going to believe these 99
lies because
it's already been telling you these
things and uh opening you up and you're
basically
trusting it you're basically submitting
to it because you you're seeing it as
like oh well it's not doing anything
wrong now now when it gets to the point
oh worship me
it's like something inside you is going
to be like whoa like
something's off you but you're probably
going to be so far gone
that you're probably going to ignore
that and you're going to start
worshiping that and it might be the most
subtle thing
and really might be the most subtle
thing or it might not be the most sort
of thing you might have that internal
resistance
because something inside of you is
really trying to like prevent you from
doing this
you know call it the fitra if you guys
want to
but something is definitely telling you
not to do this
uh so again it all comes back
to uh they
they feed you one truth with 99 lies
and once once they've reeled you in
that's when they start feeding you the
lies
and someone might be like oh well
why why the psychedelics like
psychedelics is a natural thing like you
got
weed it grows you know naturally you've
got the plants here for the ayahuasca
that grows naturally
but again like if you if you collect
everything that we've spoken about in
this podcast
and you you've read the quran like you
understand like
when adam and eve were i believe it's
the garden correct me if i'm wrong
they were told not to eat from a
specific tree
not to eat a specific fruit and what did
shaytan do he
he convinced them to eat this fruit and
for that they were
basically sent down onto the earth and
obviously you guys understand what's
going on here so it's like yes we live
in this
dunya we live in this earth but there
are things that we shouldn't consume
there are things that naturally grow
here that just are going to kill us
there are fruits that are literally
growing out in nature
and you would think i was growing it's a
fruit it's growing in nature then it's
for my sustenance
is to keep my body good bro go ahead eat
that fruit you're not gonna be alive for
another
what four or five hours after you eat
that fruit so it's like okay if you
can't eat that fruit well then it's very
obvious that there are also other things
that you can't consume
you know it has dire consequences and
psychedelics
is one of those things so
yeah tying it all together don't do
drugs kids
the intimate companion like people take
the shaytan origins
intimate companions and they say i wish
i never did that so that's how the
presentation is all it's an intimate
companionship so that that that's that's
why they're there and i also want to say
there are a current
that you say when you wake up as well so
i recommend everyone to get the book
hustle and muslim fortress of the muslim
has english arabic translation very tiny
book so
i recommend everyone to get that
inshallah and
i don't know if y'all want me to do this
but i could share
experiences that i had when i was doing
just one experience
i like when i started psychedelics like
all the cool stuff all the beautiful
things i was experiencing and then how
it led to
just the most terrifying thing and i
won't go too into details but i could
i could say this if you guys want to
just drive everything home
bro for resource purposes yeah we got
like five minutes
all right for research purposes for
science
right so i started doing psychedelics
and i had uh that beautiful feeling of
like being in the present
i was like wow this is beautiful i love
this i've i've never felt this before it
was
such an amazing feeling and then that
like stuck
that that stood with me towards like
anytime i was sober
i would always want to like retake
psychedelics just to experience that
again and then like the next time i took
it
was the same thing but then this time
it's like
i was getting like clear realizations
over like what to do in my life and i
was like wow like
these shrooms man these rooms are
something else
anytime i would talk to shrooms or
someone i would hold them to a very high
regard
and um it got to the point where i
started learning about the
pineal gland the calcification a lot of
stuff the third eye
and that's when i was like yo i would
love to be tripping as if i was on
shrooms all the time
i would love to be in that present state
and just be like
feel that all the time so i started
getting deeper and deeper into this
and i remember the first experience i
had
where it was um it was basically i was
because from the pineal gland and i
remember
i was bro i was literally experiencing
this
this reality and then from this reality
i shifted into
another reality from my explanation the
best explanation i can give
i was on top of this hill where
when i would look off there was this
ocean that was going on for like
just distance like it never ended never
ended ocean
and then when i looked in the sky there
were billions and billions of stars
and then as i looked around me there
were all these these orbs
floating around me and every step i took
they all
changed colors and each color that they
would change to
were colors that i've never seen before
in this reality
and then i remember like snapping back
in to this
and i was like wow like that was
beautiful
that was beautiful and then i remember
he was when things started going
sideways
right because like as i experienced that
i'm like yo
this is it like i'm on to something here
so it's like i basically once i i said
this is it i'm on to something
i fully submitted myself to it and i was
like all right
you know what i'm just gonna go balls
deep into this i'm gonna see
exactly what i can do what i can
experience
here and that's when things took a short
turn
and i remember one day after
a specific meditation that was like to
open the the third eye
uh like during the meditation actually
my eyes were like
shaking and tears were coming out of my
eyes it's like come on now like if i
tell you guys that right now
ah man he couldn't handle it bro
but um if i tell y'all right now like
what is that
what does that remind you of like if if
you're in a sitting position
you're fully submitted and your eyes are
shaking and like
tears are coming out your eyes like you
would say that's possession
you would say this position if something
else is in control at that point
right so in that moment you know i felt
that i didn't think anything of it and
then
after that after the meditation was done
i remember i got up
and as i'm walking through the house i
feel these like weird sensations through
my body
depending on like where i'm heading in
the house and i remember
walking into my old room at the time and
as soon as i turned the light on
there was this big shadow in the corner
of the room
and granted there's never a shadow if
the light is on
so i turned the light on there's this
huge shadow in the corner of the room
and i felt
nothing but um a malicious
like eerie incidence type of intention
and my body was locked up and all these
like waves were going up and down my
spine it's like
the moment i experienced that i was like
yeah you know i'm done with this
i'm done with this like i don't want to
take psychedelics i don't want to do any
of this stuff and
it took almost two years before i could
uh
re-bring that boundary back up
and even once i brought that boundary
back up i still decided to do shrooms
again and the moment i did shrooms again
it's like
that brown that boundary was stripped
and i started to experience all that
negative stuff again and i was like
alright yeah
this ain't for me i gotta literally just
stop this
and um yeah again there's way more
details but
to keep it as uh permissible as possible
i am uh leaving a lot of the details out
but
yeah it's to drive the point home like
don't do drugs
it's kids man that's uh that's left me
speechless to be honest but
it puts it into perspective well because
we spoke about it for all this time
you've literally lived through it so you
know exactly what's up
uh you've been there you've done that
and you know it's not it it's not worth
it
so apparently you came to that
realization now or
uh before yeah yeah i'm doing that
but yeah with that being said
it's been a great episode thank you for
being here ahmed as well you're gone but
um
thank you as well i think his battery
died yeah probably we got like what
like two three more episodes left
in the series yeah minimum two all right
well
with that being said if you made it this
far
go ahead and hashtag stay clean
dmt hashtag don't do drugs
and um enjoy the rest of your day
khalid do you have anything you want to
say good man i'm good i'll save it for
next time insha'allah all right well
with that being said assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh
the reminder is that no matter where you
are in life you know you don't know
where you're gonna be tomorrow
you could be feeling amazing one day and
then literally lose your iman like that
right the prophet of the senate said
that there will come a time where a
person is a believer in the morning and
at night they're a disbeliever
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm